verdunklungsgefahr für deutschland wenn
all das wegbricht was uns lieb und
inzwischen auch teuer ist öl gas kohle
atom für die warme stube und die
urlaubsreise russland wird als lieferant
ausfallen und wind und sonne dann muss
man erst mal einfangen also doch
zumindestens vorübergehend vermeintlich
bewährtes bewahren zb atomkraft
das ist bei uns der stich ins wespennest
weniger gas weniger öl zurück zur
atomkraft jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns seine gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist antje von
broock sie sind bundesgeschäftsführerin
beim
bnd bund für umwelt und naturschutz
deutschland
professor christian von hirschhausen
leitet das fachgebiet wirtschafts und
infrastrukturpolitik an der technischen
universität hier in berlin und hier in
berlin sind sie auch tätig führt das
deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung diw
und sie sind auch wollen wir nicht
unerwähnt lassen mitbegründer von
science for future sollte ja sie ist
chefökonomen der weltgruppe und
zugeschaltet ist uns die technik und
osteuropa historikerin anna veronika
wendland sie sind autorin eines buches
mit dem titel
atomkraft ja bitte klimawandel und
energiekrise wie die kernkraft uns jetzt
retten kann der frau ins land trotz
dieses euphorischen buchtitel
gilt die atomkraft in deutschland ja als
politisch und gesellschaftlich
abgeschrieben wollen sie da wieder eine
tote die kernkraft zum leben erwecken
nein ich will nichts tolles zum leben
erwecken ich will was gut
funktionierendes erhalten sagen was man
so denn derzeit geht ja die diskussion
auch hoch her weil wir einfach wissen
wir sind hier in einer doppelten krise
energiekrise und klimakrise und uns
gehen allmählich wirklich die
möglichkeiten aus sehr schnell und
zuverlässig co2 armen strom herzustellen
und da in so einer situation ist es halt
eher ungelegen mitten im winter noch
drei atomkraftwerke abzuschalten
deswegen plädiere ich eben dafür das
nicht zu tun er wurde erschossen man
kann ja auch anders herum denken
totgesagte leben länger heißt ja
und zwar weil sie noch gebraucht werden
in diesem fall weil die energiewende
doch nicht so rasant vonstatten geht
dass viele erhoffen und unserer atemluft
ist es ja auch nicht egal ob wärme und
strom von braunkohle kommen oder von
kernkraft weil kein kräftiger weniger
co2 emissionen verursacht müssen wir da
etwas flexibler sein weil wir nicht
genau wissen wann wir wirklich auf
fossile und
kernenergie mische energieträger
verzichten können
also ich glaube dass sowohl die die die
anmoderation die sie eben gemacht haben
als auch die tief implikation jetzt
ihrer frage am thema vorbei gehen wir
haben in deutschland ein gut ausgebautes
energiesystem was ich jetzt angesichts
der dramatischen situation in der
ukraine darauf einstellen muss ohne
russisches gas ohne russische kohle ohne
russisches öl auszukommen und zwar heute
das können wir auch das stellt die
versorgungssicherheit im stromsektor
mitnichten in frage und wir dürfen nicht
den fehler begehen das co2 was
sicherlich schädlich ist und ich glaube
sie sind uns jetzt einig dass wir co2
frei geben wollen zu vergleichen oder zu
relativieren mit dem plutonium und dem
radioaktiven material was wir in
atomkernen produzieren möchte darauf
hinweisen dass atomkraft gefährlich ist
dass sie bis heute nicht kontrolliert
werden kann was man daran merkt dass man
es nicht versichern kann dass es heute
zu unfällen kommen kann und dass wir auf
einem guten wege sind aber im
schwierigen
27 tausend kubikmeter hoch radioaktiven
abfall in ein endlager zu verbringen
wenn wir heute die frage stellen wann
wird denn das nächste kernkraftwerk
gebaut torpedieren wir diesen prozess
und das ist gefährlich wir statten sie
noch eine nachfrage meine frage ging ja
dahin ob wir uns sicher sein können dass
genügend regenerative energie zur
verfügung steht um den bedarf wir können
ja darüber nachher noch genauer reden
den wir brauchen für die chemieindustrie
für die elektromobilität dass der durch
regenerative energie vollends gedeckt
werden kann natürlich wir haben in
deutschland haben ein potenzial von 89
100 gigawatt solar-energie
onshore mehrere 100 gigawatt potenzial
an windenergie im oster paket sind
ungefähr für zwanzig dreißig
100 gut 100
gegenwind und entsprechende
solarkapazitäten des
energiewirtschaftsgesetzes das eeg
schreibt ja vor bis 2035 100 prozent
erneuerbar das heißt ich weiß nicht
worüber wir hier diskutieren wir sollten
diskutieren über das thema endlagerung
gut also wir diskutieren darüber ob
dieses ziel dass er gesetzt worden ist
auch erreichbar ist und dass er jetzt
auch gleich tun von bruck die für
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die hat ja
2011 der anti atomkraft bewegung gerade
zu einem triumph beschert atomausstieg
könnte es jetzt sein dass sie trotzdem
noch mal alle auf die straße müssen um
dem protest noch mal neu zu organisieren
wenn jetzt
sind ja noch relativ viele die glauben
der kernkraft ausstieg der endgültige
sei jetzt doch der falsche zeitpunkt
also ich hoffe tatsächlich dass wir
nicht auf die straße müssen weil die
debatte ja völlig am problem vorbei
führt
kernkraft liefert im moment sechs
prozent des stroms in deutschland also
das ist mitnichten die große lücke die
der jetzt entsteht und frau wendland hat
es gesagt
angesichts des nächsten kalten winters
können wir nicht gleichzeitig aus der
atomkraft aussteigen aber die atomkraft
ist ja keine heizenergie sondern die die
wärme kommt ja von einem anderen
energieträger deswegen brauchen wir wenn
wir über den atomausstieg reden nicht
über den den kalten winter sprechen ist
eine andere debatte da müssten wir über
energiesparmaßnahmen reden da müssen wir
darüber reden wie wir bürgerinnen und
bürger unterstützen können im haushalt
energie einzusparen
es ist tatsächlich
begrüßenswert aber ärgerlich dass die
energieeffizienz kampagne des
bundeswirtschafts- und klimaministerium
so spät kommt denn darin liegen die
größeren potenzial als die atomkraft
weiter verlaufen zu lassen
zu den vielen politischen faustkämpfen
in der ampelkoalition kommt jetzt
möglicherweise nochmal eine kontroverse
über diese in der atomenergiefrage also
länger laufen lassen von
atomkraftwerken drei sind dass wir noch
in deutschland
kann sagen so rot grün gegen fdp es gibt
ja offensichtlich habe ja herr lindner
habe heute auch schon mal die klingen in
der öffentlichkeit zu diesem thema
gekreuzt ist dieser oder wäre dieser
konflikt für die ampelkoalition wert bei
denn sie hat ja noch viele andere
konflikte zu bewältigen also ich glaube
dass der konflikte auf uns auf alle
verletzt zug kommen wird es ist keine
frage ob 420 30 irgendwie mit unseren
ausbauzielen so weit sind oder auch
nicht das entscheidende im moment ist ob
wir den nächsten und im übernächsten
winter da gut durchkommen und ich glaube
so ein bisschen fehlt ihr die fantasie
was es bedeutet wenn die wenn wir einen
energie embargo krieg oder lieferstopp
also auch für das ist ja nicht nur
unsere entscheidung sondern die russen
können es ja auch entscheiden wir hatten
das ja anfang der 70er jahre 73 jom
kippur krieg und dann war war hatten die
arabischen länder gesagt wir stoppen
jetzt mal das öl und wir waren damals
ähnlich abhängig von dem öl damals
übrigens japan auch japan hat genau das
erlebt wofür wir hier angst haben und
wenn wir uns ja manchmal wundern warum
die japaner nicht aussteigen trotz
fukushima woher die bundeskanzlerin
physikerin uns weismachen wollte sie
etwas über atomkraft gelernt die japaner
haben ihre lektion 73 gelernt dass es
tote gibt wenn die energie nicht
gesichert ist weil die hatten blackouts
die hatten mangelnde versorgung das
bedeutete an intensivstationen
krankenhäusern plötzlich ging nichts
mehr die leute waren in panik und ist
ein trauma die haben auch ihre lehre
gezogen daraus wir sollten über die
nächsten zwei winter reden darum geht es
und ich meine lindner wäre klug beraten
complus wahrscheinlich zu spät
inzwischen um noch das zu ändern in der
bevölkerung gibt es inzwischen das hat
sich gewandelt eine mehrheit die sagte
also nicht sofort aussteigen nicht
sofort abschneiden also weil die angst
ist schon da mal abgesehen von den
preisen ist es natürlich preis wirksam
wenn eine energiequelle weiter vom markt
genommen wird und zu sagen
es ist
klimafreundlicher
braunkohle und kohle kraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen halte ich für
sehr bedenklich es ist nur so die fdp es
selber die jene gewesen die mit der
union zusammen ausgestiegen ist deswegen
fällt es auch der fdp schwer sie sich da
er ehrlich zu machen los ich warne davor
was passiert wenn die leute merken ist
es teurer es ist unsicher es geht nicht
unbedingt darum sie haben vollkommen
recht atomkraft ist nicht die
wärmeenergie aber es ist natürlich so
dass es für die industrie wichtig ist
und gas geht er also erdgas geht ja auch
in den industrie das heißt es ist schon
es sind kommunizierende röhren also wenn
man gas mehr industrie
dort was abkoppeln muss wenn ein mangel
ist dann ist es natürlich schon
entscheidend haben wir atom oder nicht
atomstrom und solar im winter bringt uns
nicht sehr viel bekanntlich ganz kurz
man einhaken frohsinns was hat denn die
debatte eigentlich ausgelöst aus ihrer
sicht war das der angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine oder zweifeln an schnellen
gelingen wir sind im moment wirklich an
mehreren fronten ganz schlecht war das
eine ist werden wir kohle weiter laufen
lassen klima wir erreichen die
klimaschutz ziele weder in also unsere
eigene selbst gesetzten weder in diesem
noch im nächsten jahr wegen der kohle
die wir weiter stärke betreiben müssen
und die preise ich meine das ist doppelt
so teuer geworden was meinen sie was das
kostet
die russen stoppen den und die gefahr
ist immer da die sind unglaublich
erpressbar wir merken dass in den ganzen
moralischen fragen wie viel wollen wir
eigentlich putin an geld rüberschieben
das heißt das ist das hat schon um
denken dass wir gemerkt haben dass wir
vielleicht die falsche reihenfolge
genommen haben ich bin hier nicht
irgendwie jemand der sagt atomkraft ist
die zukunftstechnologie das kann ich
auch gar nicht beurteilen bin ich ganz
klar aber
dass wir kurzfristig eine energiequelle
die gesichert zu zeiten wo wir dunkel
flaute haben kein den und wir haben das
wir sind inzwischen an vielen tagen
abhängig von importen aus dem ausland
die ja auch davon wiederum
mit beeinträchtigt werden wenn wir noch
mehr energieträger vom markt nehmen
die frage legen wir
den bedarf den wir in zehn 15 20 jahren
haben aber dass wir jetzt unmittelbar
eben durch die unsichere
energieimporte lage möglicherweise
dadurch in eine gefährliche zone geraten
weil zu wenig energie zu wenig
fossile energieträger da sind ich rede
jetzt nur von den nächsten jahren nicht
von den 27 wichtige punkte angesprochen
kosten und import unabhängigkeit und das
ist ja leider mitnichten so dass das
uran nicht aus russland creme und die
brennstäbe in unserem camp
atomkraftwerken nicht aus russland kämen
also wir haben die situation dass wir
uns auf einen ausstieg vorbereitet haben
dass die anlagen die im moment laufen
auf den ausfall so mit aussicht auf den
ausstieg jetzt weniger regel prüfungen
hatten weniger technische neuerungen
hatten und man kann sie das wird immer
kolportiert man könnte die einfach
laufen dass man kann die nicht einfach
laufen lassen die müssten jetzt
überarbeitet werden müsste investiert
werden das kostet und wir bräuchten neue
brennelemente und die brennelemente
dauern ein bis zwei jahre bis sie da
sind also mit blick auf den nächsten
winter ist es gar keine lösung mit blick
auf die kosten ist es im übrigen auch
keine lösung atomkraft ist
ganz kurz vor dem landtag mit atomkraft
ist nicht so billig wie gerne uns
weisgemacht wird es immer noch teurer
als
photovoltaik und als wesen kraft und
zwar ungefähr doppelt so teuer ein
bisschen mehr sogar also es ist auch
nicht das kostenargument was sie bringen
und gegners ging um knapp halten und es
ging nicht
bei den lenk wissen wird es einen einen
abschaltplan geben der staatlich
gesteuert ist und wir würden natürlich
nicht die krankenhäuser als erstes
abgeschaltet werden also auch da müssen
sich die bürgerinnen und bürger keine
sagen macht ich kann sie aber auf der
ganzen breite beruhigen es wird im
nächsten winter und auch im winter
danach keine engpässe geben sie sind auf
der gass seite und sich beruflich darauf
drei studien die wir haben die wie
berlin mit forschungspartner rinnen und
forschungspartnern durchgeführt haben
eine zur europäischen gasversorgung eine
zur deutschen gasversorgung eine zur
deutschen
elektrizitätsversorgung
europäische erdgasversorgung ist
natürlich teurer geworden steht aber
insgesamt im internationalen kontext
relativ günstig da weil die potenziale
durch flüssiggas was schmutzig ist und
was keine langfristige lösung ist
vorhanden sind in deutschland könnten
wir morgen auf russisches erdgas
verzichten in der
2 bedingung die eine ist dass sowohl auf
der haushalt seite als auch auf der
industrieseite effizienter verarbeitet
wird wir reden ungefähr von 15 bis 18
und das in diesem jahr die speicher
verlaufen die speicher laufen zurzeit
vor wir haben ein speichervolumen von 24
milliarden kubikmeter davon wenn man
selbst wenn man den russischen speicher
abzieht sind das immer noch 18
milliarden darüber damit kommen wir
durch den winter und strom gibt es in
großen mengen er hat mit einem großem
nachteil dass wir
kohle einsetzen das heißt die co2 bilanz
nach 20 23 wird etwas hoch gehen aber es
gibt weder an der wärme seite noch an
der seite
ich muss jetzt langsam nehmen er
verwendete sie haben jetzt die sequenz
gehört ja
ich habe jetzt eine menge eine lange
zeit zugehört und muss jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen abarbeiten was hier alles
gesagt wo da sind es ziemlich viele
dinge durcheinander gegangen fangen wir
ganz von hinten an was von frau von prag
gesagt hat mit
elementen aus russland das ist natürlich
unsinn die brennelemente unserer
kernkraftwerke sind nicht aus russland
sie sind von westinghouse sie werden in
schweden hergestellt und ein teil des
urans was dafür benutzt wird stammt
tatsächlich aus kasachstan größtenteils
und aus russland aber die welt
uranvorkommen oder die zulieferer diesem
diversifizierter das heißt dass russland
argument was auch nur ganz zufällig
aufgebockt ist als an diese diskussion
über die kernkraftwerke anfing das halte
ich wirklich für widerlegbar dann
schauen wir uns an das argument was
immer wieder kommt die kernkraftwerke
müssten uns doch gar nichts denn es ging
ja um die wärme ja richtig es geht um
die wärme aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass ein teil des russischen
gases verstromt wird und vor allen
dingen es wird auch russische steinkohle
in unseren immer noch laufenden
steinkohlekraftwerken verstromt und
genau dieser anteil könnte man exakt
durch diese drei kernkraftwerke ersetzen
und man könnte es vor allen dingen zu
einer fantastischen co2 bilanz machen
das ist genau der punkt den ich eben
tatsächlich kritisiere dass hier eine
regierung mit ein ministerium vor allem
bmw heißt das ja also klima ministerium
mit einem klimaminister an der spitze
und was macht der geht diktatoren gas
einkaufen und er lässt die
kohlekraftwerke länger laufen nur weil
er nicht möchte dass über kernenergie
diskutiert und obwohl wir diese
laufenden anlagen haben so und jetzt
einfach noch bei der frage es sind ja
nur noch 6 prozent dieses stroms ja also
wer mal eine strommenge lage erlebt hat
der weiß dass auch sechs prozent in
einem industrieland eine ganze menge
sind und ich möchte auch daran erinnern
dass dieses argument wenn man es auf
andere energie erzeuger
umlegt halt dann auch zum doppel
standard werden kann wir haben 20 21
soviel kern strom im netz gehabt wie
photovoltaik und das argumente ihrer
seite jetzt herr von hirschhausen und
vorfand brook ist na ja das war so wenig
das ist vernachlässigbar also kann man
das auch wegschmeißen bei der
photovoltaik der gleiche anteil strom im
netz war da sagen sie genau das
gegenteil
das ist co2 armer strom das ist zu wenig
im netz das müssen wir aufbauen und
genau das ist der punkt ich was mir
wirklich auffällt in der diskussion das
sind diese doppelstandards die sich hier
raum greifen da würde ich eben sagen
lasst uns mal wirklich ganz rational
eben die frau blieb sagt über die
nächsten paar jahre diskutieren das ist
das wirklich akut hier anliegt lasst uns
über die ehrlichkeit einer regierung
diskutieren die als klima regierung
gestartet ist und jetzt ziemlich auf den
bauch landet derzeit mit der art und
weise mit dieser krieges krise umzugehen
und lasst uns letzten endes dann auch
über die performance der deutschen
kernkraftwerke reden und dann können wir
uns gerne die atommüll frage anschauen
aber dann muss ich feststellen die atome
frage und die entsorgungsfrage stellt
sich sowieso die stellt sich für den
atommüll den wir haben und der atommüll
nach oben drauf käme der wäre
tatsächlich dann er würde an dem
grundproblem der endlagersuche überhaupt
nichts ändern das heißt das ist für die
jetzige diskussion eigentlich gar kein
argument ich denke also tatsächlich
technisch ist es möglich diese
kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen
dann gibt es inzwischen genügend
expertise und auch juristische expertise
die uns das bestätigt hat die uns auch
bestätigt hat dass die bundesregierung
mit ihrem prüfer merck reichlich
oberflächlich vorgegangen ist und
deswegen plädiere ich wirklich dafür
jetzt einfach ganz pragmatisch dafür zu
sorgen dass wir diese anlage
weiterlaufen lassen
fragen stellen darf ich da eine
nachfrage stellen die betreiberfirma
dieser akw es haben ja selbst kein
interesse mehr am weiterbetrieb sie
sagen es fehlt das personal
es fehlen die der brennstoff ist vielen
auch die sicherheitsüberprüfung um das
weiter führen zu lassen haben wir
überhaupt das 2 die zeit und das geld
das tatsächlich wieder aufleben oder
besser gesagt weiter führen zu lassen
das widerspricht widersprechen der
straße erhältlich was die betreiber
sagen ist ja die betreiber folgen der
politik das muss man halt immer wieder
tatsächlich betonen die politik muss die
vorgaben machen
und dann folgen die betreiber die gesagt
haben die auch anfang märz signalisiert
haben wenn wir beitragen können diesen
notstand zu lösen dann werden wir das
tun aber das signal muss in form einer
gesetzesänderung des atomgesetzes und
der entsprechenden
rechtlichen vorkehrungen das muss
natürlich von der politik kommen aber
die frage war ja und sagt jetzt das
letzte später durch sie werden doch
jetzt durch hingehen uran die werden
jetzt nicht hingehen brennelemente
bestellen wenn sie von der politik kein
go haben die werden auch nicht hingehen
mitten in der rückbau planung für die
anlage alles umzuschmeißen eine revision
planung aufzulegen für 20 23 wenn sie
kein signal bekommen also man kann nicht
den schritt vor dem schritt machen und
dann halt den betreibern vorwerfen sie
würden sie würden ja gar nicht wollen
und es würde ja gar nichts tun wenn man
selbst den schritt nicht vorlegt und das
ist also das ist ganz zu sagen es ist
ganz eindeutig industriemarkt politiker
frau windland da haben sie vollkommen
recht weil es ist natürlich so dass
am im märz wurde ganz klar haben sie
ganz klar gesagt wir können es jetzt ist
es so dass gesagt wird ohne einen festen
zeitplan ist muss wenn dann ganz schnell
jetzt passieren bis zum sommer danach
ist es tatsächlich
weil auch die leute da nicht mehr da
sind wird das knapp ich will bloß noch
mal zu dem punkt dass wir ohne weiteres
ohne russisches erdgas auskommen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe gesagt
was anderes 30% lücke haben wir die
haben wir nicht die können wir
kurzfristig nicht schließen und die
internationale energie agentur
hat in ihrem zehn-punkte-plan was man
machen muss um unabhängig zu werden ganz
klar gesagt dass die drei atomkraftwerke
am netz bleiben sollen eben aus diesem
grund sicherheit und dass wir deutschen
irgendwie sagen wir haben ein problem
mit der sicherheit von kernkraft ist
natürlich insofern vollkommen heuchlerei
weil wir innerhalb der eu uns gerade
dazu durchgerungen haben zu sagen das
ist eine
akzeptable
energiequelle die wir noch eine ganze
weile nutzen lernen das heißt auf jeden
fall egal was wir hier im land haben wir
importieren atomstrom und wir müssen
auch froh sein wenn uns weiterhin auch
wenn wir eben weiter energie rausziehen
aus dem markt die anderen länder uns das
weiterhin so großzügig liefern können
weil wir kriegen viel aus der schweiz
wir kriegen vor allen dingen aus zur aus
frankreich und auch da ist natürlich
im zweifelsfall wenn die ressourcen
knapper werden die frage wie die
bereitschaft ist also es ist wir
belasten mit dieser politik die wir
einfach durchziehen unabhängig davon aus
die weltlage sich geändert hat
belasten wir den gesamten europäischen
energiemarkt und treiben die inflation
weiter nach oben war energie ist der
wichtigste preistreiber nach wie vor und
das ist auch ein ganz soziales problem
also ich finde dass viele von der chance
die flexibel sind wir da eigentlich mit
diesen differenzen waren die argumente
und ich wiederhole noch mal die
wissenschaftlich
belegten
fakten die die übrigens auch
veröffentlicht sind vor der von der
ukraine krise europa und deutschland
kann ohne russisches erdgas auskommen
auch im nächsten winter auch in dem
winter danach es gibt potenziale von
bestehenden
lieferanten
norwegen serien es gibt potenziale auf
der flüssiggas sei wohl wenn ich noch
mal sagen dass flüssiggas schmutzig ist
und wir jetzt nicht in so ein stranded
investments laufen sollten da ein
nordseeküste schmutz im portals für
schmutziges flüssigkeit zu bauen sondern
wir müssen den nächsten die nächsten
zwei winter
hinkriegen dass das dass das können wir
auch wenn wir auf der nachfrageseite
etwas flexibilität und gesteigerte
effizienz reißen heißt das dass das
heißt die anlagen abschalten oder was
heißt dass flexibilität auf der
nachfrageseite also das ist ja das heißt
das dass das wir
im wärmebereich
einsparen müssen das heißt temperaturen
12 grad runter machen das kriegen wir
auch
unproblematisch in das heißt dass die
industrie flexibel reagiert zum beispiel
ammoniak importiert wo ja die stoffliche
nutzung von erdgas 100 prozent ersetzt
werden kann die industrie schafft das
auch die ist flexibel wir haben auch
genug strom ich wiederhole noch mal die
strom seite ist überhaupt kein problem
sie ist sozusagen co2 intensiv das ist
schlecht ich möchte aber noch die zwei
anderen punkten genannt worden sind
ansprechen und ich wiederhole noch mal
atomkraft ist gefährlich
atomkraft ist extrem reaktiv das heißt
sie können innerhalb von
sekundenbruchteilen ein r unfall haben
wo es die
reaktion hochschaukelt das ist in
tschernobyl passiert
atomkraft ist eine
[Musik]
chance auf die hohe wärmeentwicklung der
zeichnung des permanent kühlen wenn das
nicht der fall ist kommt es zur
kernschmelze wie zum beispiel im
atomkern gemeinde hoch radioaktive
strahlung die so festgelegt im
standortauswahlgesetz von 20 23 17 1
millionen jahre eine million jahre von
menschen merck ist harmlos von wenn ich
mal die toten die uns da erzählt werden
das ist doch auch ein argument
wenn sie das wort ausnutzen können sie
das stand aus standorten auch
wissenschaftlich ist genau die ronja
aber ebenso als wendet die wissenschaft
sagt wir kommen ohne russisches gas das
ist nicht wahr es gibt eine studie dazu
und es gab eine ganze menge
wissenschaftliche gegenmeinung die dann
hoch kam also es ist keineswegs so dass
sie mit dieser position die mehrheit der
wissenschaft repräsentieren
endler die endlager für völlig fertig
werde davon dass atomkraft gefährlich
ist uran plutonium
für eine million jahre sagt gebaut
werden wenn schon von der umwelt
geschützt werden da gibt es ein
standortauswahlgesetz ich kann ihnen
gerne den linken schicken bin tätig in
einem projekt in dem wir uns
transdisziplinären mit der fragestellung
beschäftigen spreche hier aus dem
projekt nicht für das projekt und ich
überlege wie es schaffen wir faire
rahmenbedingungen
wenn wir in die region gehen nach hessen
nach franken nach bayern nach
mecklenburg vorpommern in denen wir den
menschen vermitteln hier muss 27 tausend
kubikmeter hochradioaktive abfälle und
wenn ich dann sage wir wissen nicht wie
viel
radioaktive abfälle dorthin müssen das
wan radioaktiver abfälle produziert
werden welche isotope produziert werden
dann torpediere ich zum dritten mal ein
prozess der in den 60er und 70er jahren
in gorleben schiefgegangen ist der um
die ohren um die jahrhundertwende im ak
end schief gegangen ist und wo wir jetzt
eine chance haben eine vielleicht
einmalige chance dieses extrem
gefährliche situation daß wir die die
radioaktiven abfälle in zwischenlagern
lagern beenden können durch eine
tiefenpsychologische lagerung das jetzt
hier soll jeder ausrechnen können jetzt
nicht dass zumindest die nächsten beiden
wortbeiträge fest als sv wendland dran
und dann brauche ja das problem ist herr
von hirschhausen dass sie jetzt ja
natürlich die grundsatzdiskussion über
kernenergie führen wollen und vor allen
dingen dann eigentlich wieder eine demo
modus verfallen also den modus der demo
rede das ist gefährlich und ganz ganz
ganz viel angst ja und wenn sie aus der
forschung kommen über die endlagerung
nicht kennen das standortauswahl gesetzt
und ich war selber dabei als
ehrenamtliche in dem ersten teil des
auswahlverfahrens das heißt ich habe
ziemlich gute erfahrungen mit diesen
diskussionen wenn sie tatsächlich
hingehen wollen und helfen wollen dass
leute mit vertrauen diesem endlagersuche
prozess gegenüberstehen und wer am ende
des tages irgendwann mit kerntechnische
anlage gebaut werden muss das ist
nämlich ein endlager dann können sie
sich nicht vorne hinstellen und den
leuten dauernd die message geben angst
angst angst sie müssen dazu wissen diese
eine million jahre die sind nicht
wissenschaftlich begründet die sind rein
politisch begründet dass es zu sagen
sondern die deutsche super endlager
sicherheitsmarge wenn man nach
skandinavien gucken also ein länder die
mit der endlagersuche wirklich weiter
sind als wir die finden sind fast fertig
mit endlagerbau fangen demnächst an
einzulagern die haben das auch genau so
wissenschafts basiert genau so grün sind
sehr natur liebende nationen ich finde
die schweden die haben das geschäft und
bei denen reicht eine auslegung für
100.000 jahre und da haben die auch die
wissenschaft auf ihrer seite die eine
million ja dass man überall eine
leistung die man gemacht hat damit die
grünen in dem prozess drin bleiben und
das sollten wir wirklich unterschreiben
die anderen dinge die gesagt wurden also
sicherheitsbedenken bei der verlängerung
der kernkraft da muss man auch noch mal
ganz dezidiert sagen die behauptung es
seien irgendwelche prüfung nicht mehr
gemacht worden oder verschleppt worden
weil man ja gewusst hat es ist sowieso
im dezember 2022 schluss das ist unwahr
das zeigt einfach nur dass sie ziemlich
wenig ahnung von der art und weise haben
wie diese industrie arbeitet in
kernkraftwerken müssen bis zum letzten
tag alle gesetzlich vorgeschrieben und
prüfverfahren periodischen prüfungen
wiederkehrende prüfungen durchgeführt
werden und diese anlage ist am 31 12 22
genauso fit wie sie paar jahre vorher
war weil sie diese prüfung nachweisen
müssen sonst hätte sie gar keine
genehmigung zum leistungsbetrieb und das
musst du hier wirklich immer ganz klar
gesagt werden weil wir müssen in dieser
ganzen debatte um klima und energie
diesem ruf folgen von lovis fans da bin
ich sehr dafür
und wenn wir uns hier nicht ehrlich
machen und bei der kerntechnik und immer
nicht mehr der stars folgen sondern hier
einfach angst botschaften in der raum
stellen dann kommen wir nicht weiter und
dann werden wir übrigens auch nie es
schaffen vertrauen für ein endlager
aufzubauen wo immer ist auch dann in
einem wissenschaftsbasierten prozess
ausgewählt und stehen wird und ich
glaube das ist eine ganz wesentliche
problematik unseres atom des kurses in
deutschland allgemein ganz abgesehen von
dieser problematik dass wir jetzt ganz
pragmatisch für die nächsten 2 3
schauen müssen wie kriegen wir unser
energiesystem von russland unabhängig
gemacht und die kriegen wir es auch
dekan und muss es gibt ein problem noch
zu klären diskussionsstil wer wie viel
oder wie wenig ahnung hat von der sache
ist natürlich einer solchen fällen
diskussionssendung momentan schlecht
endgültig wasserdicht zu klären von
druck endlagerfrage es gibt ja eine
position in der in dieser diskussion die
sagen also brauchen nicht noch mal
atomkraft viele jahre sondern sollten
die beiden die drei atomkraftwerke
die noch am netz sind ein paar jahre
weiter laufen lassen um diese
befürchtete energie lücke zu überbrücken
was würde das bedeutend für die
endlagerfrage wenn diese drei
atomkraftwerke noch weiterlaufen würden
für eine kurze zeit also
es ist ja sowieso schon irrsinnig
gewesen mit der atomkraft anzufangen
ohne die lager frage geklärt zu haben
dass ein bisschen wie mit einem flugzeug
starten und die landebahn ist noch nicht
gebaut und jetzt wo wir das stimme ich
herrn von hirschhausen absolut zu wo wir
im mitten im prozess sind ein ort zu
suchen jetzt zu sagen okay wir
verlängern das noch mal um die
produzieren noch mehr müll das ist
kontraproduktiv für die debatte und ist
es auch das setzt diesen irrsinn ford
deswegen ist es
meines erachtens wirklich die falsche
lösung aber ich habe noch einen anderen
gedanken wir befinden uns in einer
kriegssituation ist herrscht krieg in
europa wir wissen nicht ob weitere
europäische länder angegriffen werden
kein einziges atomkraftwerk auf der welt
ist krieg sicher und ich rede gar nicht
davon dass die von von raketen getroffen
werden könnten sondern ich gehe davon
dass das haben sie ja gerade ausgeführt
herr von hirschhausen dass die
permanente kühlung funktionieren muss
und ich weiß es gibt diese reaktoren und
ich weiß es gibt da rückfall positionen
aber das ist eine sensible technik die
kaputtgehen kann durch durch eben
kriegsgeschehen und in so einer
situation wo man sie sagten dass frau
siemens wir wollen das risiko mindern in
so einer situation nicht gott froh zu
sein dass wir ende des jahres raus sind
aus einer risikotechnologie sondern die
noch weiterlaufen lassen das ist mir
unbegreiflich das verstehe ich einfach
nicht wollte dazu noch
unterwegs ist oder etwas nicht stimmen
muss auch sehen dass wir atomstrom aus
frankreich importieren im moment ist es
so dass in frankreich 50 prozent der
atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet sind aus
technischen mängeln und frankreich
massiv strom importiert nicht exportiert
und das merken die stromkunden in
frankreich nur deswegen nicht weil der
strompreis staatlich gedeckelt ist aber
es ist eine teure
technologie hat uns 2029
erheblich
es geht doch nicht um eine gesamtbilanz
zu jedem tag mehr sondern es gibt dunkel
flaute wir haben inzwischen
ihr einen hohen anteil an erneuerbaren
in dem bereich strom erzeugen der
allerdings ja auch nur ein fünftel der
gesamtenergie des gesamten
energieverbrauchs ist also wir reden ja
immer um kleinen teil
und da sind wir sehr abhängig vom
ausland geworden und zwar in beiden
richtungen wenn wir nämlich viel wind
haben müssen ist das auslands- und
teilweise zu kosten nicht dass wir uns
auf das bezahlen strom abnehmen und wir
kaufen genau dann werden woanders der
bedarf auch sehr hoch ist das heißt zu
den teuersten preis genau da ist ist
derzeitig in auch wenn es vor ort genau
da die atomkraft ein problem weil die
atomkraft überhaupt nicht flexibel ist
also ein wir brauchen
wohl unterscheiden und wir mussten wegen
der atomkraft die erneuerbaren energien
regelmäßig runterregeln die atomkraft
ist keine brücke die atomkraft ist ein
retour in ein altes energiesystem was
den umbau und den brauchen wir heute den
umbau zur erneuerbaren energien
verhindert aber wir brauchen auch
energieträger deswegen sind wir ja so
abhängig von erdgas und kohle und atom
der zu solchen zeiten wo die
erneuerbaren weil die eben nicht
regelmäßig kommen der dann zur verfügung
steht und wir bezahlen zwischen dafür
dass kohle kraftwerke am netz bleiben
ohne dass wir sie eigentlich neben
wollen aber nur dafür dass sie da sind
wir bezahlen industrieunternehmen die
bereits sind notfalls runterzufahren
ihren strombedarf nur dafür dass wir
eben sagen können wir bauen aus eine
unsichere energie also unsicher in dem
in dem angebot weil es eben zwölf
schwankt sehr stark so ist das nun mal
mit wind und sonne und das ist alles das
ist alles auf längere sicht erleichtert
gleichgestellt machbar aber die
speichertechnik haben wir auch hier in
deutschland haben wollen weil wir angst
haben davon wir haben sehr viel und das
einzige wovor ich angst hatten war uns
abhängig zu machen von russland also und
zwar weil uns die wissenschaft bestimmte
wissenschaftlich uns immer gesagt hat es
funktioniert alles die war ja sehr stark
auch an diesem gast interessiert weil
sie unbedingt atom raus haben wollte und
kohle wegen der starken co2 belastung
nur wir sehen ja jetzt wir müssen doch
flexibler agieren werden sich die
bedingungen ändern und es geht doch nur
darum zu sagen pragmatisch gar nicht auf
auf die nächsten 20 jahre und 30 jahre
wie das andere länder machen sondern
erst mal kurzfristig weil der ausbau der
erneuerbaren dauert und er
würde
geben und dann kommen wir genau zu
diesem thema verwendet bitte
ja nur noch mal um das zuletzt gesagt
ein bisschen an die fakten
zurückzubinden weil auch ganz gerne in
die diskussion derzeit immer sehr auf
frankreich gezeigt wird es ist zb gar
nicht wahr dass in frankreich die hälfte
der kernkraftwerke wegen defekten
stilllegen sondern ein großer teil liegt
wegen verzögerter revision im normalen
wartungs stillstand also nicht wegen
dieser systemischen effekte die wir
außerdem in einigen lagen haben so das
ist das eine zum zweiten wenn wir dann
irgendwann wie sich dann frankreich
schlägt stellen wir fest dass immer noch
frankreich mit seiner hälfte von
kernkraftwerken immer noch hier jeden
verdammten tag ungefähr fünfmal co2
freier ist als unsere
elektrizitätswirtschaft und wenn wir
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich auf uns selber
gucken ich habe mir mal die letzte woche
angeguckt wie stehen unsere erneuerbaren
energien und dann vergleicht das mit
frankreich und dann sehe ich halt das
zeitweise unsere windkraft zu 80 zu 92%
und verfügbar ist unsere photovoltaik zu
50 zu 60 prozent das heißt mit dem
finger auf frankreich zeigen und zu
sagen ich hier sind 50 prozent der
kernkraftwerke vom netz nützt uns nichts
denn wir haben unsere eigenen
hausaufgaben nicht gemacht und wir
erfüllen genau wie frankreich dann die
lücken die entstehen fossil und das tun
wir weil wir schlicht die reihenfolge
vertauscht haben wir hätten zuerst aus
der kohle aussteigen müssen und dann aus
der kernenergie unterdessen haben was
falsch gemacht und das ist genau was uns
jetzt auf die füße fällt und das letzte
der letzte punkt immer wieder beliebt
die frage wie flexibel sind
kernkraftwerke und auch da muss ich
sagen dafür dass sie alle als
energieexperten durch die gegend laufen
haben sie erstaunlich wenig ahnung von
dieser energie technik ja die deutschen
kernkraftwerke wurden bereits als
geplant wurden als last folge fähiger
anlagen geplant und sie können das auch
und sie beweisen dass übrigens auch da
können sie sich gerne mal die laster der
deutschen kernkraftwerke angucken die
fahren also lustig den erneuerbaren
hinterher im mittel lastbereich und
können das wird gradienten von bis zu 30
megawatt pro minute da kommen die
durchaus mit einer guten gasturbine mit
man das heißt wir sehen hier lauter mems
und flemmings und ziemlich schnelle
urteile und wenn man mal richtig auch
die faktenlage guckt dann stellt sich
das alles ganz anders
mainz
meine äußerung von gerade das ist etwas
schwierig ist aber neben inhaltlichen
äußerungen auch noch haltungsnoten
vergeblich würde aber weil wir nur noch
sechs minuten zeit haben gerne noch
einen anderen aspekt wichtig war dass
ich ja damals gesagt ja ich habe ich ihn
ja als auch die gelegenheit gegeben das
zu äußern ich würde noch gerne einen
anderen aspekt den wir schon kurz
angerissen haben herr von hirschhausen
sie haben man sich vorher ziemlich
sicher oder vorhin ziemlich sicher
zugesagt haben wir erreichen diese ziele
die wir uns gegeben haben was die
regenerative energieerzeugung an gibt
aber da steht ja viel davor die
windkrafträder sollen erheblich in ihrer
zahl erhöht wie wir brauchen dazu
flächen die müssen ausgewiesen werden da
gibt es widerstand die
photovoltaikanlagen müssen alle
produziert werden das ist ja sind ja
unmengen auch bei den ganzen rohstoff
problemen die wir im moment haben die
stromtrassen ist ein unsicheres problem
weil es gibt unglaublich viele
widerstände dagegen gleichzeitig habe
wie ein e mobilität das ist gestern
beschlossen worden dass in europa ab
2035 keine brenner motoren mehr gebaut
werden sollen wir haben enormen
energiebedarf bei der chemieindustrie
das geben ja auch zum beispiel die
bündnisgrünen zu dass da noch viel
regenerative energie menge erzeugt
werden muss was macht sie so sicher dass
wir diese ziele erreichen unter diesen
prämissen die ich gerade genannt habe
und den möglichen einschränkungen die es
auf den weg dahin gibt na ja wir haben
die technischen möglichkeiten
uns von der von den fossilen unabhängig
zu machen und uns von der atomkraft zu
verabschieden
durch erneuerbare und durch flexibilität
optionen wie zum beispiel das ist ja
nicht richtig dass speicher wesen nicht
entwickelt wurde im gegenteil die
netzbetreiber zum beispiel unser
netzbetreiber 50 hertz wir sind zwischen
für 100 prozent erneuerbar die
argumentation ich kenne die weil ich die
selber unterrichtet habe in den 80er und
90er jahren das ist eine grundlast
braucht und dann kann man so ein
bisschen erneuerbare die ist auf den
kopf gestellt worden durch die letzten
20 jahre wir können ein system
problemlos 100 prozent erneuerbar fahren
mit entsprechenden flexibel ist die
option
die rassenfrage die habe ich mir seit 20
jahren angeguckt die ist wichtig aber
die stellt kein problem dar weil wir
netzbetreiber haben die effizienz sind
und weil wir de facto sogar eine gewisse
überkapazität haben an netzausbau ich
möchte den letzten punkt bringen weil ja
hier die rede gewesen ist von fakten und
der atom kernkraft atomkern kraft das
muss man sich klar machen hat nichts und
hat nie irgendetwas mit dem ziel zu tun
gehabt wirtschaftlich strom zu
produzieren sondern atomkraft gibt es
weil in der nachkriegszeit versuche
gemacht wurden die militärische nutzung
zu ergänzen durch eine kommerzielle das
aber hoffnungslos schief gegangen dass
wir daran merken dass damals 1950 er
jahren atomkraftwerk um ein vielfaches
teurer war als andere energieformen und
heute wieder und in der zwischenzeit ist
das immer so gewesen gerade wenn man aus
einer ordnungspolitischen perspektive
kommt die sie ja eigentlich auch
vertreten dann ist atomkern kraft
nicht vertretbar weil die risiken nicht
versicherbar sind weil es generationen
ungerechtigkeit gibt und da ist dann
auch egal ob es 100.000 jahre oder eine
million ja als unvorstellbar und das ist
kein element einer nachhaltigen
transformation also wie man es auch
unvereinbaren mit den zielen der
energiewende die ja aus den 70 jahren
kommt aus einer nuklearen kontroverse es
geht um kerntechnik und nicht um anti
oder für atom das ist so sinnvoll wie zu
diskutieren ob ich für oder gegen ja
gravitations frage ich finde es
interessant dass die netze unwichtig
sind weil das hört sich ja ganz anders
ja da erstaunt mich so viel wenn es um
planbarkeit geht und was man erreicht
dass wir über diese große stromtrasse
süd link dir den vielen strom
erneuerbaren strom aus dem norden gerade
von der nordsee richtung richtung
süddeutschland bringen sollen wo er
jetzt auch noch mal dann zwei akw s
abgestellte
abgeschaltet werden ende des jahres dass
dieser 2012 zwar geplant wird aber noch
nicht ein
kilometer gebaut ist das da frage ich
mich diese planung auf dem papier nur
der fachkräfte man ist jetzt schon
gigantisch ingenieure sind dafür nötig
handwerker sind dafür nötig die die
produkte die dafür nötig sind für die
erneuerbaren sie brauchen nämlich ja
auch rohstoffe sind auch vorwiegend in
russland und china die da ihre hand
drauf haben also so ganz dass wir ein
bisschen was plan auf dem papier und das
so ohne weiteres eins zu eins umsetzen
ich finde bei staatlicher planung habe
ich da manchmal meine zweifel ob das
immer so klappt und ich würde mich ja
ganz gerne flexibel halten würde ich
ganz gerne an der stelle in kurzen vor
punkt machen punkt kommt dann nach dem
was ich hier noch fragen wollte zum
schluss robert hable hat gesagt wir
müssen eigentlich auch im prinzip auch
viel mehr lernen energie zu sparen das
geht aber nur wenn alle mitmachen sind
sie da optimistisch energiesparsamkeit
das kann man leicht fordern aber wenn da
nicht alle mitmachen wird schwierig also
es ist tatsächlich so dass wir 10 bis 15
der energie einsparen können durch ganz
einfache
bewussten energieverbrauch sie haben ja
immer noch stand bei im system wurde
energie verschwendet wird und auch die
meisten industrieunternehmen haben
energieaudits gemacht die haben die in
der schublade sie könnten sie jetzt raus
holen und umsetzen und da bin ich
optimistisch denn je teurer der die
energie wird ist so mehr wird man darauf
gucken wie man günstig energie sparen
kann und energie nicht zu verbrauchen
was sicherlich die beste also das heißt
preis und kostendruck werden da ihren
teil dazu beitragen gut dann bedanke ich
mich war ja eine lebhafte diskussion ich
bin dann nämlich bei an die von profis
wird man höhere chancen bei dorothea
dienst und bei an aronica wendland für
die diskussion liebe zuschauer am
sonntag um 13 uhr zeigen wir ihnen
nochmal ausschnitte des
aufsehenerregenden auftritt von angela
merkel diese woche und danach gibt es
dazu eine phoenix runde sonntag 13 uhr
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit thomas
bade darin neues zu der amokfahrt vom
gestrigen tag hier in berlin bleiben sie
bei uns
[Musik]